hey guys what's up this is andrew for
sentences.com so in this video guys i'm
here to make an analysis on x united
states steel corporation a steel
producer guys we have something
happening here so let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys i'm gonna start on the
weekly time frame this time all right
because i'm analyzing x so x is still
producer you guys know that we have a
bull run on the communist market
because of the russia ukraine war i'm
not sure what's going to happen
regarding this war that is very sad once
again but i think that the impact we're
seeing is like a long-term change for a
lot of sectors commodity sector included
and i am monitoring x for quite some
time guys look at this all right so i'm
here on the weekly chart that is
starting in 2008 guys and we can see
that this company has seen its value
dropping guys from 200 to you know
almost close to zero guys to five all
right so it's a very brutal move down
since then we are bouncing back so
we are in a very nice situation because
as you guys know so i'm using here
logarithmic scale if you use a regular
scale you don't see anything as you can
see here so in this situation
logarithmic scale is very adapted and
here guys we are having luke so i
connect this high i connect this high
and here since may 21 we are having a
nice build up right guys a build up as
you can see
so what does it mean it means that the
market is consolidating just below a
resistance okay so everybody can see
this resistance because we have many
reactions so this makes this resistance
visible for many traders and i can tell
you that there are a lot of stop losses
placed just here guys okay in this area
a lot of stop losses okay
just above so
sellers are all here they're selling
here we have buyers here all right it
was not very clear i started to be in
this trade around 23 around here i
shared this trade in my discord of
course at that time we're having a
triangle like that so you know it just
transformed into a flat but it's still
this
same build up that we're having here so
what will happen now guys i think we are
about to break out okay let's be very
clear i think we're about to break out
you can even watch this on the monthly
time frame you know and it's still
looking very good guess it's a very long
term movement and once again guys when
you have this kind of consolidation and
then you have a breakout everybody can
see it and a lot of traders will jump
into the straight so did the breakout
occur or not yet it's not clear to me we
are 28 i would say the breakout level is
around 29 so on a weekly timeframe as
you can see the volume is still low
because we're in the middle of the week
guys uh so of course the volume is not
complete if i go on a daily timeframe i
can see some volume increase here but
it's not on the breakout day so what i
need to see i don't have it yet guys but
i'm giving you this
before the event happened so that you
can be ready if you are interested no
financial advice what i'm looking for is
a huge green day something like that but
with a breakout okay and as i am looking
that on a weekly time frame guys those
who are with me on discord be prepared
to receive an alert soon uh maybe on
friday if on friday we have this big
volume above 28 29 this would be for me
a signal that we are starting to move
higher so whenever this situation
happened this kind of situation happens
guys you know the target is quite easy
to find and by the way guys i'm
explaining all of this this is a nice
situation but i can't give you all the
details of how to analyze that because
it takes too much time but you have a
lot of information coming from volume
momentum and volatility that i explained
very well in my course guys and i can't
repeat that enough this course will help
you so much to predict market tony's
point if you want to be a trader guys
take this course you still have 50
discount until uh sunday this sunday
march 5th or 6th and yeah once again
guys it will really help you to
understand everything you need to know
to start become successful in your
trading if you are not already and if
you're already successful guys you're
just going to become a very very good
trader so i'm here showing you a little
bit how this is working but i'm using
that guys forever and at the beginning
of my career i would love if someone
would have given to me what i'm giving
you guys in this course so this is the
reason why i did that because you know
people need to know and retail investors
they don't really know
exactly what to look at and you know
professional shadows it's easier because
we have you know experienced traders
working with us that are telling us how
things work so you know i'm just trying
to do the same things that i would have
loved someone that had done with me and
i personally learned most of what i'm
teaching guys by myself but once again
take this opportunity guys it won't last
forever so here if we do have this
breakout then usually we go to the first
recent high which is at 47 so we might
see something like that and i can as
well add earlier to f3 one two three
four five we are missing a fifth wave
it's kind of obvious i can also add the
short interest guys x is a company that
is attacked by shorts because we have 17
percent of regular short interest and we
have a lot of options we have 3.7
percent of synthetic short and we can go
up to 14 with the max pen at 25
uh for march 18th which means that the
25 strike is the one where we have the
most open interest which means that if
we go across this level we will have
nice moves happening this is the reason
why here we had those last days those
plus six
you see plus
plus 10 plus two
plus four you see you you're gonna have
big moves across this level so it can go
on the downside as well for now we don't
have the breakout but we have a lot of
gamma here which means that option
market makers need to buy on the upside
that will help the bullish momentum to
happen so yeah the 40 strike is also we
also have some positions here and after
40 we don't have anything more so this
is in line with the 47 target this
target might be reached maybe in may
something like that all right maybe air
pro you see in one or two months i
personally have some calls uh on x i
think it's a good position to have and
yeah it's it's pretty much it yeah last
thing guys let's check quickly i haven't
done that the fib extensions okay so fib
extensions are telling us you see
between 35 and 16 so 44 is a one to one
relation between one plus three and five
so 44 is a good target so you see i
think we would we would go between 40
and 50 within two months if we have this
breakout and i'm gonna be here to let
you know so if you guys enjoyed this
video please don't forget to click on
the sub like and bell button so you're
gonna be the first to know when i upload
anything new and stay close to show i
see you guys